hi my name is christopher hicks
i am currently living in in boston
massachusetts but i'm
from montana but nonetheless big fan
i'm an alcoholic and in recovery for
quite a while but nonetheless catching
the endurance bug and finding
endless inspiration from your story
right now currently training for the rut
50k
at sky running ultra endurance race in
big sky montana
so some friends and i are racing from
around the country but
my question is how to optimize training
for altitude um
race is the race is actually ranging
between 7 000
up to just over 11 000 feet but uh
living at sea level how was it
that i could optimize my training here
at sea level in order to benefit my race
um coming up in september so
anyways any tips tricks uh or just
opinions that you have that would be
great
all right thank you good question
christopher thanks for that
um there's a couple things that you can
do some are expensive and some are free
and i'm sure you've probably already
heard of these i mean you can of course
uh purchase an altitude tent right
and sleep in that every night what is an
altitude
you haven't watched alexi pappas's movie
no no i have not
track town yeah she she her whole
bedroom is set up as an altitude tent in
this movie that's hilarious yeah it's
basically a pressurized
tent that you can put in your bedroom
and sleep in that
approximates um the uh
what it's like to be at altitude by like
you know it's a reduction in the amount
of oxygen
basically that acclimates you to
altitude
and then when you go out and you go out
of the tent and then you train
you're obviously at sea level so you get
this boost so it's the back and the
fourth
like a decompression chamber kind of
sort of like that yeah and i
actually don't know how expensive those
things are i just assume they're
probably
crazy expensive um hardcore endurance
junkies
uh swear by them um of course you could
take a weekend trip to altitude and try
to get you know some training in
you know at 7 000 feet i don't know if
that's possible especially during a
pandemic
and obviously that's something i'm sure
you've
that's occurred to you right at some
point so i don't know how helpful it is
for me to
to mention that um another thing that
that some people
um have expressed positive results
from is wearing a training mask which is
basically like it
kind of looks we're all wearing masks
right now but it has like a gauge on it
and it reduces the amount of airflow
that you get
i think it's just trainingmask.com but
yeah there's running in your mask alone
could do it could you do something
basically but but there is a difference
between
um at true altitude
there it's a low there's a lower oxygen
content in what you're breathing but
you're not restricting
airflow okay and there's something
different about
restricting the airflow while the oxygen
ratio
remains the same that
scientists have basically said this is
not
this is a pretty ineffective way of
approximating altitude training there's
an article
on train right about this i'll link it
up in the show notes
basically do altitude training mass work
for endurance athletes the
essential conclusion is really not so
much
it might be good for mental training
though to like feel what that feels like
to have a little bit of a reduced
just to sort of prepare yourself for
that experience
but short of an altitude tent or being
able to train at altitude
um there are certain things that you can
do in training you might want to over
index a little bit more than you would
ordinarily on
interval training and hill training
you're training for a 50k
trail race it's probably uh you know a
pretty zone two approach
um that wouldn't require a lot of
interval training or like hill repeats
high intensity stuff but there are
indications that
weaving that kind of work into your
daily routine not your daily routine or
your weekly routine
can have some benefits and how your
body's going to process altitude
i also would suggest arriving
at the event as early as possible you
know as many days
in advance as you possibly can what
would you say would be
ideal well seven days it really takes
seven days to acclimate
um you may not be able to go a whole
week ahead of time to
reap that benefit but every day i think
is going to be a little bit
better if you can do that so that you
can get used to it a little bit
i also think you're going to have to
boost your hydration
and your caloric intake at altitude your
needs are going to be different
so over indexing on hydration and carbs
is going to be important and short of
all of those things
as you just go out and train on a daily
basis anticipate that the suffering
you're going to experience
is going to be different than what
you're experiencing in in
you know in boston running around
running around massachusetts
it's going to be harder so just start to
wrap your head mentally
around that and adjust your expectations
accordingly because nothing really
compares to training
um at altitude or racing at altitude so
you gotta
let go of whatever goals you have around
pace and time
and focus on exertion right because
that's
really the only metric that's important
in trying to train at sea level and
race at altitude right like you're
whatever your garmin says about your
pace like is meaningless
because it's going to be a lot harder
and you're going to suffer
is your hydration 2x would you say
that's a good question
i i think it's a personal thing i
wouldn't i wouldn't say
2x off the bat i think it's something
that is going to be different for
everybody
um but just to be mindful and ahead of
it
i think is going to be important because
you get that lung burn when you first
run at altitude right like it's the
worst
yeah yeah yeah and then you feel like
you're the only one who's feeling that
like there must be something wrong with
me or i didn't train or this is going to
be terrible
so i think just mentally you know
preparing yourself for that
is is is something that um would be wise
to do
and if he gets there seven days early
how many runs should he
get in well i think you should go if you
get there seven days early go to the
highest point that you can because
there's probably a variety in elevations
you know once you get to the venue
um so the the more time that you can
spend at the highest altitude possible
and doing your your
training leading up to the event i think
will be beneficial as well
[Music]
you